Alex Trebek is sharing his story with
the release of his new memoir the answer
is reflections on my life and during an
appearance on Good Morning America the
longtime jeopardy host reveals if he's
thought about leaving the show after 36
seasons you will never walk away from
that show Alex I think I will well maybe
I misrepresent myself when I say I will
walk away maybe I will crawl away so but
still as long as you can do the job you
can't find a reason you would ever want
to stop correct the job you are
absolutely right when it comes to who he
would choose as his replacement on the
hint game show Trebek offers an
unexpected choice I joke with the
audience and I say Betty White it's good
call because they want somebody younger
yeah somebody funnier she checks all
checks all those boxes Betty and I have
been friends for a long long time
meanwhile the host also opens up about
the hairpiece he's chosen to wear on
camera after being diagnosed with stage
4 pancreatic cancer last year and you
talk a lot about the hair in the book
this is not me
and as long as I'm on chemotherapy this
will always be here when I'm in public
and that's fine if I were no longer
hosting the program I would not be
wearing the hairpiece and during the
discussion Trebek shares his thoughts on
young people who have floated the proper
precautions during the Cova 19 pandemic
a cavalier attitude towards this
pandemic on the part of our young people
especially we've lost over a hundred and
thirty thousand people and the young
people just hey if you don't want to
catch it don't don't go out you know huh
kind of an attitude is that there isn't
enough caring out there as far as I'm
concerned